hey everyone it's a metallic birth from
BuzzFeed podcast see something say
something
and this is the bun a ceremony but na
means coffee in Amharic and the ceremony
is found in both Ethiopian and Eritrean
households personally I found out about
it the first time from my partner's dad
who is Ethiopian and he made it seem
like this super big important thing so
we decided to learn more as a couple I
was just looking back at some of our
wedding photos and I think one of the
things that I love about our wedding
is that your mom is Pakistani but your
dad is Ethiopian and so we included all
those things in our wedding things I
didn't realize how lucky I was growing
up having two rich vibrant cultures I
think was one of those things that is
very much something that is handed down
from like mothers to daughters and with
my mom being focused on me she didn't
share with me because she doesn't have
that language either that's definitely
something that I know has enriched my
life and I would like to you know kind
of like maintain so I found this place
in Bushwick called blue McCafe that
actually does but a couple times a week
and serves it to the people and the
restaurant so tomorrow there's oh
there's a woman and she's basically
agreed to let you shadow her being her
abunai apprentice then you are the head
chef here and I can say Brooklyn
learn how to do canard in Ethiopia
basically in every house we're making
parties but something that you pick up
when I moved to in the US that part was
kind of gone my mom is an alibi so every
time I do cop to serve when it kind of
no time for me like I only like 15 20
minutes you have to keep moving it so
you can get the perfect color they do
you make us look so easy
good yeah yeah just keep moving it now
you can go around let people smell like
don't keep moving it again
don't bury them okay yeah yeah yeah my
grandma which you would like make us
stop what we were doing and she's like
go grind
[Music]
it's really good it tastes different
it's a lot cleaner or something and you
don't put milk in or anything no no
sugar thank you guys for doing it
thank you for speaking puts up properly
so Khadija gave us some of the green
beans yes which we will probably try to
attempt and I'll do this to leaveth part
I'll do like the grinding and second
hand and you'll lead it it is my
apprentice now because I am a clearly
Abunda scholar
[Music]